in the last few videos we saw that if we
had n points n points each of them have
x and y coordinates so let me draw n of
those points so let's call this point 1
it has the coordinates x1 comma x1 y1
you have the second point over here that
has the coordinates x2 y2 and then we
keep putting points up here and
eventually we get to the end point over
here the end point that has the
coordinates x and y n what we saw is is
that there is a line that we can find we
can find a line that minimizes the
squared distance that minimizes the
squared distance so this line right here
I'll call it y is equal to M X plus B
that there is some line that minimizes
the squared distance to the points and
let me just review what those squared
distances are so it's sometimes it's
called the squared error so this is the
error between the line and point 1 so
I'll call that error 1 this is the error
between the line and point 2 and point 2
will call this error 2 this is the error
between the line and point 3 or you're
sorry and point n so if you wanted the
total error if you want the total
squared error and this is actually how
we started off this whole discussion the
total squared error between the points
and between the points and the line you
literally just take you literally take
the y-value at each point so for example
you would take y1 that's this value
right over here you take y1 minus the
value the y-value at this point in the
line well that point in the line is
essentially what the Y value you get
when you substitute x1 into this
equation
so I'll just substitute x1 into this
equation so minus mx1 plus B this right
here that is this Y value right over
here that is MX MX 1 plus B I don't - I
get my graph to cluttered so I'll just
delete that there that's the first that
is Error 1 right over there that is
Error 1 and we want the squared errors
between each of the points in the line
so that's the first one then you
the same thing for the second point and
we started our discussion this way y2
minus M x2 plus B squared all the way
all the way I'll do dot dot dot to show
that there are a bunch of these that we
have to do until we get to the end point
all the way to yn minus m xn plus B
squared and now that we actually know
how to find now that we know how to find
these M's and B's I showed you the
formula the next factor we've proved the
formula of how to find these M's and B's
we can find this line and if we wanted
to say well you know how good is it how
much error is there we can then
calculate it because we now know the MS
and the B so we can calculate it for a
certain set of data now what I want to
do is kind of come up with a more
meaningful estimate of how good
something this line is fitting is
fitting the the data points that we have
and to do that we're going to ask
ourselves the question how much how much
or we could even say what percentage
what percentage of the variation
variation in in Y is described is
described by the variation variation in
X and so let's think about this how much
of the total variation in Y there's
obviously change variation in Y this Y
value is over here this Y this points Y
value is over here there's clearly a
bunch of variation in the Y but how much
of that is essentially described by the
variation in X or described by the line
so let's think about that first think
about what the total variation is how
much of the we could even say total
variation how much of the total
variation in Y so let's just figure out
what the total variation in Y is the
total variation it's really just a tool
for measuring total variation in Y well
we care when we think about variation
and this is even true when we thought
about variance which was the the mean
variation in Y is we think about the
squared distance from some central
tendency and the best central measure we
can have
why is the arithmetic mean so we could
just say the total variation in Y is
just going to be the sum the sum of the
distances of each of the Y's so you get
y1 let me do this in another color you
get y1 this y1 over here
this is y1 over here you get y1 minus
the mean of all the Y's minus the mean
of all the Y's squared plus y 2 plus y 2
minus the mean of all of the Y squared +
and you just keep going all the way to
the nth Y value to yn minus the mean of
all the Y's squared this gives you the
total variation in Y if you you can just
take it all the Val all the Y values
find their mean it'll be some value
maybe it's right over here someplace
maybe that is the mean value of all the
Y's and so you can even visualize it the
same way we visualized the squared error
from the line so if you visualize it you
could imagine a line that's y is equal
to the mean of Y which would look just
like that and what we're measuring over
here this error right over here is the
square of this distance right over here
between the first Y between this point
vertically and this line the second one
is going to be this distance is going to
be this distance just right up to the
line the the nth one is going to be the
distance from there all the way to the
line right over there and then there are
these other points in between this is
the total variation Y make sense if you
divide this by n you actually will get
the I should say this is the total
variation in Y if you divide this by n
you're going to get what we typically
associate as the variance of Y which is
kind of the average squared distance now
we have the total squared distance so
what we want to do is how much of this
how much of the total variation Y is
described by the variation in X so maybe
we can think of it this way so our
denominator we want what percentage of
the total variation in Y so let me write
it this way let me call this as the
squared error from the average let me
call this this is equal to the squared
error maybe I was call this the squared
error from from the mean of Y and this
is really the total vary
and why so let's put that as the
denominator let's put that as the
denominator the total variation Y which
is the squared error from from the mean
from the mean of the Y's now we want to
know what percentage of this is
described by the variation in X now what
is not described by the variation in X
we want how much is described by the
variation X but what if we want what if
we want how much of the total error how
much how much of the total variation how
much of the total variation is not is
not described is not described by the
line over here is not described by the
regression line by the regression line
how much of the total data is not well
we already have a measure for that we
have the squared error of the line this
tells us the square of the distances
from each point to our line so it is
exactly this measure it tells us how
much of the total variation is not
described by the regression line so if
you want to know what percentage of the
total variation is not described by the
regression line by the regression line
you would just say this is the total it
would just be the squared error the
squared error of the line because this
is the total variation not described by
the regression line divided by the total
variation so let me make it clear this
is this right over here this right over
here is tells us this tells us what
percentage what percentage of variation
of the total variation is not is not
described is not described by the
variation in X by the variation by the
variation in X or by the line or by the
regression line regression by the
regression line so to answer our
question what percentage is described by
the variation well the rest of it
has to be described by the variation in
X because our question is what
percentage of the total variation is
described by the variation X this is the
percentage that is not described so if
this number right here if this number is
I don't know 30% if 30% of the variation
in Y is not described by the line then
the remainder will be described by the
line so we could essentially just
subtract this from 1 so if we take 1
minus the squared error between our data
points and the line over the squared
error between the data points between
the Y's and the mean why we have we now
have a percentage this actually tells us
what percentage of total variation total
variation is described by the line is
described is described you can either
view it's described by the line or by
the variation in X its described by the
variation by the variation in X and this
number right here this is called the
coefficient of determination this is
called the coefficient of determination
it's just what statistic statisticians
have decided to name it coefficient
coefficient of determination of
determination determination and it's
also called r-squared and you might have
even heard that term when people talk
about regression now let's think about
it if the standard if the squared error
of the line if the squared error is
really small if the squared error is
really small what does that mean it
means that these errors it means that
these errors right over here are really
small are really small which means that
the line is a really good fit which
means that the line is this at right
line order it tells us that the line is
a really good fit so if the let me write
it over here
if the squared error of the line is
small is small it tells us that the line
is a good fit line is a good it tells us
it's a good fit now what would happen
over here well if this number
is really small this is going to be a
very small fraction over here one - a
very small fraction is going to be a
pretty large it's going to be a number
close to one so then so then we're going
to have our R squared will be close
close to 1 which tells us that a lot of
the variation in Y is described by the
variation in X which makes sense because
the line is a good fit you take the
opposite case if the squared error of
the line is huge if this number over
here is huge if this number over here is
huge then that means there's a lot of
error between the data points in the
line and so if this number is huge then
this number over here is going to be
huge 1 1 - there's going to be a
percentage close to 1 and 1 - that is
going to be close to 0 and so if this if
if the squared error of the line is
large is large it is large if this is
large this whole thing is going to be
close to 1 and if this whole thing is
close to 1 the whole coefficient of
determination the whole R square is
going to be close to 0 which makes sense
R squared will be close to 0 which makes
sense that tells us that very little of
the total variation in Y is described by
the variation x or described by the line
well anyway everything I've been dealing
with so far has been a little bit in the
abstract and the next video actually put
this will actually look at some data
samples and calculate their regression
line and also calculate the r-squared
and see how good of a fit it really is